show your party I have a penis Wow
don't read the check right corporate
Craig getting a big just one Pikachu huh
isn't what Pikachu yeah buddy I keep
Pikachu around where's mom we do you run
a long time
hey Kraig I heard you got an are you oh
I'm cheating the monitor are you gonna
whip it out you got on Black Friday
that's cool
nice come on just have fun so you can
walk fluffy could you believe us hey
cookie hey guys boast about the shirt
tag what are you askin are you ready no
you know people are asking are you upset
no I'm tired I had to work on
I got a message oh yeah what do you say
I'm fighting again to the party
hey good hit there we go yes thank you
me doing I got to redo Sunday night I'm
sorry about that
they got Rockets our spot we know oh I'm
gonna flank not kill that guy
oh god this is why I just [ __ ] that up
not they're gonna get me
oh my blade trying to survive got it oh
sorry man
thanks for the appreciate there's two hi
there they're just lobbing [ __ ] over
here hit him Steve him in there Steve
show me more show me more
[Laughter]
the leaves on one today huh all right
we're doing some try yields but hey we
going now all right
yeah I got raucous trading left hi I got
the guy I'm hurt I'm dead
sorry Cub yeah I keep getting [ __ ] at
catch I think I got to come around the
back a catch he's one dude he's out
there he's running toward the bomb what
is it it's a counter got it and what's
the map it's on the board go
jump down it's that it's that map with
the castle on the inside outside I
forget what it's called um I'll call ya
you know grotto
it's got castle on the catch oh all
right it's got the wind in the willows
it's got the boners and the jams
yeah I'm with you buddy mm-hmm thanks
pika all right they're all sir naughty
so hurt all right
give me one second nice it's not yeah
[ __ ]
good [ __ ] there we go
I'll get it I'll get it cranked missed
that he downloaded I'm just gonna grind
on my own why don't we play playstation
his agency gave the free one [ __ ]
thank you something here to get now
we're gonna it's always
[Laughter]
oh I just went what is Bobby getting
back on we don't know when Bobby is
getting back we just heard you 20 that's
gonna make like some would come back and
help with the flank Golden Gun help me
over here
these Rockets and the Rockets don't even
[ __ ] with it
I'm getting you right now what are you
gonna do there we go okay back in the
game my girlfriend is over
[Music]
[Laughter]
where if you've never mudbath
little my behalf do don't mix it up
right here we talking about you know I
mean need my [ __ ] so what is this our
first win or second we're honest it's
really good
whatever time Warren I'm Warren Spahn
I'm using it right now that one's good
that's really [ __ ] good it's super
fast if you liked like the triptych
dragon or whatever the [ __ ] what's
called fine
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[ __ ] stupid what's going on always
one hurt outside there one coming around
yeah I don't know we gonna concentrate
we're all over the map here give me your
phone the truth comes out Greg is over
there [ __ ] up somebody else is
reading chat each other like you're not
each other we know when you say somebody
you mean how's that I still get it get
it get it
okay just messin how is he still alive
you guys take out he's coming behind me
you guys got anything [ __ ] he is right
behind me no I'm talking them off I'm
cutting em up no they got there we don't
have it they gotta what the [ __ ]
happened what the [ __ ]
again distract
I'm in general no no it was a tone no
Craig get a tone oh I didn't I didn't
told you we can't tone where's uh
where's Frankie Frank yeah he's in no no
he's out of town he's in no Sacramento
right now I believe you know what I need
to do next Sunday's I need to just come
over to my thing yeah yeah return I kill
somebody
I'm setting the charge friction I get
you if you want but just one guy left
Boxey where is he where's II justjust
watch them watch the bomb they come in
from Castle sight hassle do you're right
yeah
help them yep lower to get back stay
alive can't raise anybody else
hey [ __ ]
let's come back which one that these
guys aren't that good what's going on
Oh like some less of trouble go pick you
chief executive kitty oh crank don't get
excited
we got a circle we need to make a shirt
called Kady [ __ ] yeah yeah what did I
do
you guys gotta listen we gotta get this
watch out slow-mo grenade Oh
Oh help I got to to hurt you in there
t-bag
wow that's silence I know crappy this
[ __ ] we traded nice coke just
help coke with these guys there you go
nice I just wanted to win okay well they
got to know if I end they got it's
Heather let's go to catch guys oh my god
there's gonna be a couple here yep
you just keep running
Double Down
joella's need help
[ __ ] man Greg I wouldn't worry about our
minute man yeah there you go miss Bea
good job well they have to come to us
yeah I know oh yes yeah I final David
Eick I like I love David I gotta Nova
yeah they gotta know then PI I'm gonna
watch if they go to catch they're coming
this way that's the Warlock - need help
- what's the catch
oh [ __ ] I'm gonna get Nova where's
everybody's all over
wow that was a hey Griffin you wanna you
wanna play some file Griffin what's up
in Gryffindor
ah not sure maybe he's making [ __ ]
killing babies making babies
god you're so crass reptilians okay I
don't know I wouldn't be able to get new
car okay I'm coming yeah okay cool
anything I'll be back he's getting some
eggs getting smoked yeah now he's a
smoker oh that's good no I don't think
Craig's a lizard David Icke and his
theory on Jewish people being lizard
reptilians
oh my god oh my god the chicken the
worst chat once okay we got we got a
boot Craig my pleasure with it with
pleasure huh
yes with even more pleasure now
[ __ ] Pikachu where are you at I'm
here some intimate put me in crap Yuto
said he loves you Griffin
Beto's crap Ito weird real names why is
he called crappy toe toes crappy what's
up Tommy why don't why doesn't Griffin
do no-shave November all year that's a
long time
I love you guys rice and pan face cook
that use the rice I don't see Griffin I
don't see you online I am though are you
oh yeah neighbors might now let's go
flawless so we can rub in Craig's face
where she would Pikachu maybe we'll get
the best man oh look at this
dead orbit shoulders there's gonna be
guys guys gonna be around this week at
all
regular on alright hell yeah dude we'll
hit some recording - alright wanted to
come on say hello for a little while you
guys are already playing with four so I
think we should plan to do the raid next
week yeah our whole group yeah we can do
that alright let's just make that a plan
what I'll do and I'll go over Craig's
I'll bring my xbox over to Craig's yeah
that'll be cool I can't do it we don't
like when you say that didn't sound
right that should be a t-shirt let him
up
get need in there got one super hurt
super here
it's super tired
dammit nice Matthew Arthur I'm getting
you up yeah alright you can get me
anybody's around me
Steve camp but Pikachu can I don't have
a token can you provide me our math
about it yeah banana you wanted to do
some iron better yeah
no what about you guys he left
Griffen difference gone he said he said
he looked at Katie's though and he said
his has become better than yours no he
doesn't play as much that means you're
playing worse
I wanna meet proud of that there goes
the voice what happened or do you do not
get we're just not getting team shots
man like I don't know what [ __ ] pikachu
get Taylor [ __ ] absolute I'll let you
go in to save the day okay what can I do
better than okay yeah let's see it lets
see it
oh come behind you alright Vaughn here
Steve oh you said that catch ya catch
hey go get it over here homie no there
we go there we go there we go
yep healing rift he's got Rockets [ __ ]
there's another one to the side he's so
hurt Oh Paul's for made you [ __ ]
nice muskie yep get that [ __ ] he's off
to the side he's coming he's coming
someone's go through the middle there No
God we could have had that I thought we
said it I couldn't see him to verse one
man there's that be one person the other
guy down you gotta give them time like
there's two people on the bomb the I
want to pick up a gun real quick all
right nice man
one really hurt if you get eight on that
left side I'm pushing got 1.23 [ __ ]
drink
there we go good
I'm telling you swallow one of those ah
one when those ah ones get nervous cider
nice peach is about 43 I'm flanking you
can occupy a Herot one I got one I got I
got the one with the rare get heavy that
one
what's doing alright one's gonna be
flanking down hitter nice man he got me
there's two of them flanking from behind
ones coming your way mess key right here
recover recover from the pulse I'm
looking
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
there's no it's I'm going
[Music]
[Laughter]
Oh lamb I heard down he's down he's down
[Music]
[Laughter]
just kidding just kidding let's just say
I'm glad you're doing a checkout Stevie
B's patreon guys oh yeah
[Laughter]
let's do it what's the plain ones hurt
what is it down there
number one last hope 305 57 young Jamie
on your podcast who's young Jamie
Easons like these Joe Rogan's like
George Kim Oh kind of
looks like they're hanging back here
yeah it's gonna get hard behind you all
right wait wait first I hit boys yep
yeah I'm happy
got one down he's on left side I'm with
you Arthur
okay dude Wow [ __ ] yeah they killed me
hey Steve trying get the rocket launcher
dude he's in the diesel nice mess
there you go get in there no we got it
Oh No yeah that seemed fast Bob I asked
James gene but he's still one hop on my
show
let's go catch what about your energy
all right they're going middle there
ones coming from the side well wasn't
weird they're hooked I got on you good
kill
what kind of move is that disappeared
right in front of my eyes he's a very
talented dancer Oh can't see anything
god oh my god Chuck ins is it a glasses
oh come on laughing all right guys here
new team shots man that's all it is
[ __ ]
just came back they're going to catch
yep all right I'm getting rockets
they're finally that diffuser right
go change them I got it album nice
that's it there we go let's come back
come on pick it - I know I want you to
try what's going on I don't in the bed
watch - help me - BK you stay with coke
Stevie watch - with me help help
hunters what's going on over there
in our asses catch man the pressure if
you don't get a kill our next step so
it's gonna be called look at how bad
Pikachu is gonna kill I'm bananas up
next [ __ ] sakes
oh my god we're not doing random neck
get shots I got a kill I'm sorry scan
your card though here we'll get a new
car banana or me yeah you gotta make a
choice but Pikachu go always talking
smack whatever question is a Steve how
strange that what is that thing it's a
super
I was doing fine we did trials
watching you play you're pretty good oh
we're still playing oh [ __ ] I thought we
already we're done with these guys
I'll come on [ __ ] pressure intense
all right here we go oh yeah are you
going I mean it's a private party
[Laughter]
man you pissed out Griffin with that
comment make it Griffin looks like a
Tyrannosaurus Rex maybe chef picot
should read all the comments you can
concentrate got win some come on Pikachu
[Laughter]
let's flank him
you got this arctor I think I gotta come
on Pikachu count on you there you go as
you feel there we go go catch
nope so there I go there we go on me I'm
nice good job help me help me Dylan
oh man well would this guy quick out man
he glitched oh yeah this cheating g.o
switching legs
what do you see miss appear to be
helping them too much I'm not on chili
yeah I gotta concentrate on target
report them reported ah yeah maghen what
there cheating's nice
hmm you guys you say me thanks Galactus
whoa any plan to pick up FIFA 18 I want
to I do want to play fifa for sure
I like its really good student oh well I
heard you like kick a ball oh he got me
damn ghost Primus man nothing [ __ ] me
up those promise doubling down the dojo
nice mask you Oh get that good job guys
Pikachu get a bunch good job the only
dad was yeah good team we round them up
he thought banana was coming in you
should do a blog where you and your
brother play fifa no I'd love to see you
play against kalila though no I didn't
get the chance to shoot real guns these
guys we're supposed to take me the gun
range I'm looking at one of the guys
birthday Horace sleeve I know
quick I'll take you anytime you want to
go yeah I don't know if I trust you
around guns oh hey Steve I gotta tell
you that Hey look
mother was really good bro you'll shoot
next episode next episode for a long
time so Joe you too world that guy's
huge
yeah yeah guns guns good watch out Kurt
yeah you were changed here your ills to
high caliber rounds I think it is on it
yeah I know I've gone viral fan face but
I don't know I don't want to fight him
anymore
sorry you know it's all loved there now
we got so compared to remember what it
used to happen you've talked about
everybody online knows
[Music]
[Applause]
so how many wins have we gotten what's a
record tonight three yeah maybe
no we in a row we we always lose our
third we do yeah we won that last one oh
we won the last vulgar we have to win
this one guys looks pretty legit yeah
looks pretty sick
what's up your time your time looks
pretty legit oh thanks man
I like the shaders no I like it I like
the optics oh this guy's good huh last
hope the last dance is that good that's
it spring sit there all bless oh yeah
they're not there
dude who's no other
nice I'm just trying to fly it
see much our Bonnie watch her behind
what's behind [ __ ] this dude get them
vulgar Healy rip oh my god I didn't get
any of them I got one yeah pushing in on
your phone that's pathetic
he blinked out of the way there we go
flaw that out coke you're fine this year
right huh yeah probably
that's okay yeah I'm gonna get heavy
let's do block push very push they got
her we got we got a few [ __ ] dick
dick so I was trying to get back got one
[ __ ] push me right
oh stop the guy was using um nice dude
oh yeah suck it for you man coke oh yeah
oh yeah man face get [ __ ] hammered
together
[Music]
yeah close this guy Irvine Irvine two of
them won back the
Double Down
good didn't get it bad the first game
I'm doing better now
oh hell yeah oh just did you shake the
rest off yeah I'll stay back and get the
heavy and I've been out here I think
it's gonna be catch let's do one more
you're the best they get heavy thank you
cuz they're going to get it this Creek I
knew yeah they got Rockets citizen so
break em up I'm trying to get him
they're trying to play he's hurt that
you got me on the ride
come on Pete always [ __ ] behind me I
had no chance
ah damn sorry guys my fault
no it's not go are just a team he's
absolutely on their coke have you got a
grenade
dad him one behind you coke need help
Peter can't see this [ __ ] no survive
ticket food
post grenade oh just soup yet she is
kilvo what what I don't know what you're
saying you speaking English Nobel means
Gilbert okay yep I'm waiting for heavy
sea yes we said it or they said it
they're setting but I'm waiting forever
here there's one over here somewhere I
can last hope cheese they haven't gone
yet
got a little Ben nobody's [ __ ] witty
was waiting for waiting for me being me
I'm not their head no I didn't yeah I
did
I got their fuse I got a few guys oh
alright Steve come on let's focus okay
okay come on I want to win too
two down [ __ ] I guess it meskhi name I
think I've got my super to storm trans
it seems like they've gone to catch one
every single time
yeah they are good yeah I'm just making
sure we get this heavy I'm gonna try and
get this guy he like - he Nova bomb me
Nova bomb me don't what the hey Steve oh
my god sorry nervous
oh oh no they're catching up cuz the
other guy was getting heavy he was there
dude
did you kill that humble the guy on the
top he's dead and then I died stop
computer
we'll pull the two that hurt him
what's flanking got him oh you got me
Adam it doesn't make sense they're gonna
go come on I'm gonna get I got a star
now - I got my Nova Stevie be careful if
you can just throw that Nova in the bomb
hope I catch ya
I can how did they not die from that
no nice all right all right we happen to
know he's not a stone there's there's
there's no supers no more supers guys
follow me let's go catch okay nice Craig
keep going get the other one you can get
hurt ah what happened I'm saddened give
me cover you know I'm jumping I'm lucky
you bastard get that super get out of
there Stevie back out if you have to
we're getting getting heavy
yep all right get it I'll cover you no
you take it
they're coming in with glass off well I
got the tight damn it die blinking in
there nice tea got me the rod No
and so night falls
yeah I want to try to get Trivium poon
and let's try one more
I know oh we got to reset our cards
right cards yeah counselor real quick
yes cancel let's reset Steve still
you're just not gonna read chat guys
thank you could said okay I'm ready I'm
gonna name ler you make it nice here
pristine give me a break give me like a
three-minute break folder is a new card
yeah you could get the next one banana
all right let me smoke I'm just trying
to
[Music]
it's prosecutor
nothing here looks like it's gonna be
catch it's you come inside
no you put believe in yourself Steve
someone said it well then I got it I got
it I got it now I'm back
I can be revived yeah Stevie trimer
Valuev coke nice nice
there you go good service so where do
they compete Pikachu with the SAS as
what they said I'm going it they're
going catch yep
catch me if you can
all right that's good that's heavy
show your body show your body
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]